okay it's now my pleasure to introduce
our second speaker who also happens to
be my direct boss so professor there
Weber is the head of the school of
effects in statistics of University of
Sydney he graduated with PhD from here
oh I'm in 1981 and throw most of his
career at the University of Sydney he's
been head of school for the last time
this is the fifth year i believe to
think like them could you see him again
um i can say as a member of staff that i
think he is in fact universally admired
by all the staff and that's very rare
for in school with university center in
2001 the statistical Society of
Australia awarded never Webber honorary
local bishop reserves to a professional
organization of national and new south
wales branch level where he's been
active in committees of things ever
since he was a postgraduate student he's
also had a long connection with
secondary mathematics syllabus
committees the High School Certificate
examinations and you suppose HSE
standard-setting operations he's been on
the acara advisory board for the new
national quick little bit mathematics
chair review suppose HSC mad max its
owner's equity in 1998 1999 see the
judge for mathematics for the first HSC
stay off don't go up forever and ever
and ever and ever again oh yes so I
think I'll just get it come on give his
presentation
someone's after a cookie allocation for
next year us has been thanks for one
another sub 3 battery I'm job thanks for
the opportunity to come along juvie
asked me to come on and said you've got
10 minutes to talk about the eight are
scaling and some of the issues
associated with mathematics at the
moment thank you no pressure well some
of these issues have been touched on
previously but just to reinforce
statement that the 80 is a rank it's not
a mark it's not a score in terms of your
average exam mark or performance it's of
rancors your position or presenting your
position relative to a particular cohort
and it's calculated using data that's
provided by the New South Wales border
studies now Oscars and so it's looking
at the HSC group in terms of generating
the various parameters that are reported
about the HR calculation so the IB and
other programs they get eight hours
calculated using a different procedure
and that's not what we're on about so
it's an index that's used to assess
University places and if you're applying
for university positions you'll find
that there are still some degree
programs that have specific
prerequisites like actuarial studies are
unfortunately very few these days the
current government funding formulas for
universities has meant that universities
are pull back from having hard
prerequisites for having assumed
knowledge statements which gives them
flexibility in taking students into
their programs and this is an increasing
problem in the stem areas where students
are not necessarily coming in with the
appropriate the sea of knowledge in
mathematics all candidates who've met
the formal three requisites of then
ranked on the eight hours as one of the
criteria that used the support of the
most widely used one but for many
degrees there will be other criteria
like the special tertiary admissions
test interviews auditions portfolios if
you're going to the college
the arts and so on so there are a number
of criteria used to allocate University
places and many universities now have
flexible entry or bonus point schemes
and it was it's become apparent that a
lot of people are not aware of these
schemes and it's an area that maths
teachers in particular need to look at
very closely when they're advising
students because in most universities if
you look on their web pages in the stem
areas that science technology
engineering you'll find that they're
offering bonus points for candidates who
have got to unit Matthews score a band
for five or six the number of points
will differ depending on the degree and
that we find this point to play tackle
the extension courses so students should
be aware that if they put the extra
effort and take the more challenging
course part of the game if they're
playing the game about trying to
maximize their our car is to look at
what was their performance be in terms
of the bonus points that they be offered
if they are able to sort of do the two
unit and score a band for all better if
that's one of the degree programs
they're going pulpit but the number of
bonus points vary by degree and they
vary by universities that you need to
look across the spectrum but almost
every University has a web page which
will detail that information but you've
got to get a degree by degree
technically there's no sort of nice
summary to grab the colleague of mine
jakiro me to university of wollongong
talks about students sort of mortgaging
their future by choosing to be general
rather than two unit mathematics because
it's a short-term gain they're trying to
maximize their outer for entry purposes
but then they will struggle when they
get to university if they choose one of
the science-based health sciences
technology engineering programs but they
find that they really do have to get on
top of calculus and its applications and
those students will then have problems
to completely university degrees in
time so the answer to jon's question
last year there was seventy thousand six
hundred and eighty six people who
completed at least one board developed
force this is a course that we could use
in the out our calculation that it has a
formal exam fifty 4642 candidates met
the criteria to receive an utter and see
I'm in the stat section of the school
and there were twenty seven thousand two
hundred and two different course
combinations of which 19,000 576 were
taken by lunch too gnarly so the HSC is
extremely flexible as John's are
probably the two flakes of the times
when you're looking at the selective
schools entrance tests all the
candidates do the same papers and so you
just add up the marks and it's very easy
to rank the candidates are all doing the
same mix of topics moduli some
fine-tuning for special consideration
but with the HSC it's an extremely
flexible program so you've got students
coming with very very different course
combinations and they're all applying
for these various University programs
you need to have a way of ranking them
and the HR is what's being developed as
a way of helping universities in that
process through with this high volume
number of applications for a very large
number of degree programs and the
decisions all have to be processed in
those few weeks over christmas after
christmas new year so that students can
enroll in mid-january when you look at
the HSE marks we can't use those marks
directly because the align marks in the
raw marks are not competent across
subjects when you look forward move to
the new standards based HSC there was no
effort made
so ever to me say that a band six in one
subject met the sayings of 86 and
another so the align marks can't be
compared unfortunately the papers
produced rank tables based on the number
of band sixes and this is sort of
destroying student behavior because of
dance it's impossible eating is not the
same as advancing tonight an extension
and I still fear of mass comments and
the raw marks aren't comparable because
the exams are very different the wrong
max I'm comfortable one year to the next
ever because you know you have heart a
for an easy paper whatever it will
distort the patterns of marks so
squirming tries to determine the
strength of the competition in each
course it's really focusing on students
ranks in your subject and how they
perform relative to other students and
that subjects and then how those
students to perform across the range of
subjects that we've taken thus coming
parameters are calculated each year so
this is shifting candidature from one
year to the next happens very rarely in
the big subjects like mathematics but
having said that English standard last
year there was a big shift in English
Studies came on board 5,000 students
basically pulled out of English standard
and so the standard of any standard went
up and the skull Martha was the first
time in fact the only time I think the
media marketing restated has been in
vain for the HSC and the skull mark
shifted noticeably flip Standard English
because there was a huge shift e11 year
most of the other changes have been
quite gradual in most subjects the with
a bit of nudging UAC we've got the
report on the 2013 HSC is now up on the
UAC website and that's the URL given at
the bottom of the page there and that
has all the details about this going
process last year as soon as the HSC
results are released the next day when
the ACARS are available the scaling
information call information goes up on
the UAC website that day so that the day
after the agency release date you'll
have all the scaling parameters a song
subjects the tables are at the back of
the report go up onto the UAC website at
that point so you have access to all the
hard data at that time what's gone up
now is just the explanation some of the
features that have been highlighted in
the plenary part of the report ate our
eligibility most of you will be aware
having gone through the system what the
conditions are for the award of an HR
but as mathematics teachers the one that
you need to be aware of when you're
advising students is the first one these
four subjects if you're in the school
where you have extension to mathematics
you're occasionally come across students
who want to do extension to mathematics
three units of English and three units
of music or four years of English for
you with some nuts and two units of
chemistry those situations they've only
got three subjects and so they'll run
foul on that first point but so you need
to be careful in advising students about
their subject choices to make sure that
they meet all the criteria to be
eligible for an 80 now the actual
scaling the scaling uses the raw HSC
marks these are not the align marks of
the reported for students with the
actual scores they achieve on the exams
themselves and then the moderated school
assessments the school assessments are
moderated using the Royal HSC marks to
get value for the fifty percent school
assessment those two raw marks are then
averaged to get a course mark and
throughout we'll talk about marks out of
50 per unit because although most
subjects r2 unit subjects there are some
one unit extension is ammonia in
subjects like studies in religion one so
on so the first step in this coming
process is to adjust all courses to a
common top mark and then to essentially
create said scores so move everything to
a mean of 25 and the standard deviation
of 12 that first step effectively takes
out the differences in the exam papers
from one year to the next because now
whether it's a hard exam or a very easy
exam the first step in the process to
move everything to a major 25 so and
common standard deviation so if you look
at the data for mathematics we've got
the wrong means they're on the HSC oops
sorry did you guys have that much pal
obviously don't elegance with you should
be sorry top fiddle with you oh sorry
last year was a tough a year 2012 was an
easy exam so the average wrong mark was
31.6 out of 50 vs 27 but when you look
at the alignment marks when those exam
papers the group of judges come in and
decide what would be the performance
that would be indicative of a student it
was just bad sex or just BAM five and
then those marks are aligned we get the
HSE means roughly the same of the skull
means a roughly the same from year to
year the next step is to calculate the
skull mean and standard deviation for
each course and the scale mean for a
course is the average of the skull marks
of the students in all those subjects to
take a course so you get a massive
system of simultaneous equations that
have to be solved if you're that way
inclined fortunately going to do it by
hand and then that gives you the scaling
parameters for the two unit courses than
the extension courses the scale off on
the basis of the performance of the
extension students on the column two
unit paper with variations for history
and mathematics intention to whether
structures are slightly different the
next step is to calculate the maximum
scale Marxist step in the process was
introduced in the late 1990s before the
HSC change because people were gaining
through the thought and in the old HSC
the top mark was always said at 50 and
50 or a scale to 50 and so there was a
drift out of the more challenging
subjects into the easier subjects if
you're a an able student to try and get
close to 50 or get 50 in that subject to
help with your aggregate so the process
was put in place to essentially Kappas
it was called at the time the maximum
mark is set as a certain number of
standard deviations beyond the scale
mean so the course has a low scale me
indicated again sort of lower than
average ability candidature then the
maximum mark would be brought back from
50 between the mass community general
mathematics is the course where that
shows up for all the Ellen articles
50 so the maximum mark the general maths
last year was 45.7 so students cannot
score more than that terms of a
contribution for scale mark I take in
general because the mean in that course
is quite low a 21.5 remember the 25 is
sort of overall average need of the
courses once we've got the scaling
parameters you essentially unpicked the
said schools and do a little bit of
issue a bit of adjustment to make sure
you don't overshoot so no one gets more
than 50 out of 50 to get the skull marks
for each candidate you then pick the 10
best units two units of English from the
8 best are the units perform an
aggregate and the aggregates then inform
the candidates rings the ranks are then
reported against the corresponding year
seven color so the HR just takes the
ranks given by the aggregates and
reports them as if our ranks relative to
the year seven cowboy and in New South
Wales about sixty-three percent of the
year 7 cohort went on to achieve an HR
in year 12 last year ok so the big
issues HSE participation and gender
issues from the first table you can see
there's been a massive increase in the
number of students do we know
mathematics and that's more market for
females and disco Mars shifting
candidatures if you look at the I'm
giving the percentage about our eligible
candidates to do extension to extension
1 and so on because they use percentages
because the number of canvas has changed
quite dramatically with the change of
school leaving age to 17 the number of
students going through the demographics
are changing but you look the
proportions extension to as stayed
fairly stable extension ones have a
small decline since 2001 when the new
HSE came in general stayed fairly stable
and the two unit only which has had a
substantial drop so students are driving
from to Europe in general and then from
general in genomics initiative the
interest in the performance of two unit
only versus general students were
managed
without the data on the scale means and
standard deviation to percentiles for
the two unit only candidate candidature
not the combined two unit and extension
candidature so those things are broken
down to all in the report you can pick
those up off the web and if you look at
the scale means over time you find that
the extension courses have been
remarkably stable since the new HSE came
in general mathematics and the
mathematics to you and only have both
increased so with shifting cabbages and
improve the quality of the character in
both groups if you judged by the scale
mean but that's not necessarily a good
thing to mathematics